(soldiers shouting)
(guns firing)
- [Narrator] This video
posted to social media
by a Ukrainian Battalion
claims to show their soldiers
crossing the Dnipro River by boat
into Russian occupied territory
in Southern Ukraine in January.
(soldiers shouting)
(guns firing)
An example of the risky
cross river operations
that Ukraine has stepped
up in recent weeks.
The Dnipro River runs through Ukraine
from its northern border through Kherson
and into the Black Sea.
It has served as the southern front line
dividing Ukrainian and Russian forces
for the last several months.
For Ukraine, penetrating
this part of the front line
is critical for two reasons.
First, it prevents Russia
from sending troops stationed there
to other areas of the front.
And second, regaining
lands south of the river
would disrupt Russians supply lines
and bring Ukrainian troops
to Crimea's doorstep.
(artillery shuffling)
(boots thudding)
(engine purring)
Ukrainian raid teams have been challenging
Russians control here for months
according to analysts from Janes
and the Institute for
the Study of War, or ISW.
(soldiers shouting)
An analyst from Janes says
that during a typical raid
small boats likely cross the river
a few kilometers from
their desired landing,
and then ride along the bank.
The unit would then
disembark from the boat
at least a kilometer from any target
and infiltrate the rest
of the way on foot.
(gun firing)
These attacks have
increased in recent weeks.
By the beginning of August,
Ukrainians launched a new effort
near the Russian occupied
village of Kozachi Laheri.
Video posted on August 9th to Telegram
by a Ukrainian reconnaissance team
shows an artillery barrage on
the outskirts of the village,
possibly the precursor
to one of these raids.
Another clip posted that same day
appears to show a Russian combat vehicle
under fire nearby.
ISW's mapping of the front lines
shows Ukrainians claiming
ground west of Kozachi Laheri
on August 11th and 12th.
Satellite images from August 15th
reveal traces of concentrated shelling
around Russian trenches
west of the village.
The next day ISW's Frontline map
shows Russian forces
pushed Ukrainian troops
back across the river.
(soldier shouting)
(gun firing)
But analysts say these
raids have already created
a headache for Moscow.
(soldiers speaking in foreign language)
And the threat of more raids in the future
means Russia may need to choose
between risk and control of
part of its southern front
(rocket launcher swooshing)
or defending other major hotspots.
Russia has lost ground recently
in the Zaphorizhzhia region.
Fighting continues around Bakhmut
and Russia is attempting an
offensive in the Northeast.
By continuing to attack
along the Dnipro River,
Ukrainians are stretching
out Russian forces.
And tying up troops here
means it's less likely
they can be sent to these other locations
where Russia needs them.
(dramatic music)
Russia's US Embassy didn't
respond to requests for comment
and Ukrainian special
forces declined to comment
on the attacks in Kozachi Laheri.
(engine rumbling)
In the months ahead,
defending the Southern front
may become an even bigger
task for the Russians.
(gun firing)
North of the now destroyed Kakhovka Dam,
the riverbed is drying up.
Analysts say this could
allow the Ukrainian army
to send forces across on
foot or in military vehicles,
putting even further pressure on Russia's
already thinly stretched forces.
(dramatic music)
(soldiers shouting)
(guns firing)